hi lease and hello Lisa how are you yes
hello
first women's for chesty first Jim's
been working on his impression yeah yeah
he's doing lieutenant Dan now good if I
do this if I do if I snap in point that
means it was good what does that mean
friends like it meant the freedom you
have they would do that on friends yeah
when they were younger and they did it
in front of their parents that's how
they hide it this is weird I'm used to
staring at you right but now you get to
stare Jim
now I stare at you and I get a different
angle of your face better side so this
could ruin our whole relationship I'd
rather you be over here because I have a
dimple on this side and I just feel
cuter that way right well I'll take your
word for it okay great yeah but you're
delightful from the front thank you so
much what's the description of those
glasses or are those just like purely
for cosmetic restrung ger glasses so
these are you know I used to just wear
them to drive in for distance and now
it's like facial recognition is
important because people approach me in
a very fan like manner and I often when
I don't have my glasses on feel that
maybe there are a co-worker like I know
everybody in the world and then as I get
closer I'm like oh my gosh
I don't know this person and I just
approach them with some sort of
compassion when really I want to slug
them so the glasses have become a
straight-on safety feature okay
to help you from when you approach
people yeah you do have to worry about
being too familiar with people oh yeah
lisanne is also my real name so you know
people just walk up you're like hey Lisa
what's up and I'm like mmm do i ER yeah
yeah how do you uh have we met or was it
just you that knows me but you have been
in situations where it's like
you'reyou're being overly familiar you
think this person you know and then
they're just a creep yeah and you
welcome now you've welcomed them into
your life right when I've been polite
which is
always the wrong video how do you know
they're a creep though what gives away
that they're a creep
usually there's a couple tag things that
would be said like I watch your scenes
every day that probably would not be a
friend of mine like letting me know that
in the first they wouldn't just say that
you for no reason right they say because
they're super proud of it you were like
I'll even watch the same thing on
Netflix every day I mean I do watch ESPN
every day so I can relate to that but I
can't relate to watching porn every day
it seems a bit excessive why do you
watch ESPN every day uh because they do
fantasy sports I do it here on Sirius
but I go through my different shows that
I watched a little bit in a Phil Network
a little bit ESPN and listening to the
channel you know so just bein
feed-through
there's some things you know there's
there's musics that are like triggers to
I'm in a hotel room and this is the only
channel that I know what it is right
you're on the road and it's great
backdrop meanwhile you're like you know
answering some emails whatever but I
prefer actually radio you do yes yeah
why'd you stop doing film did you get
sick of it or do something you always
want to just be like I gotta move on I
just needed a change you know I need to
see what else was out there and and it's
been a great adventure because
challenging yourself to leave everything
that you know is definitely one of the
most frightful experiences and walking
away from 99.9 percent of your income is
also frightful so it's been a great like
these past three years you've watched me
go you know it's been three years now
and well and it's been a year since I've
been here full-time because I lived back
in fourth LA New York for about three
years
do you miss it or no do I miss it I miss
it more now than I did when I left for
sure I can definitely see the amazing
things about the business that were
awesome and I actually think that I'm
cooler for doing it because now my life
is like I do radio I study sports stats
I've read I've read up on injuries my
life is kind of you know boring right so
now I look back and I'm like alright you
did something pretty cool the fact that
you had that right yeah you actually now
there's enough separation where you're
like but I did all that yeah yeah yeah
passport stamp got to meet a lot of
great people traveled the world dressed
up like a political figure you know like
these are all things on the resume that
I'm like you know what how many years
did you do it 24 years you did five year
break from shooting scenes but I was
always on the road dancing or involved
doing adult bookstore appearances and
and so I'm doing appearances again just
like some bookstores some trade shows
and it's actually like super
entertaining going back now you like it
now yeah because I'm a fly on the wall
we talked about it before and I was
listening to the I guess a preview
episode of your new podcast yeah making
the time to listen it's so I tried to
the link was not what my link was no
good Eleni send me a bad link that you
play nice I think that you know she's
not the most computer savvy person in
our lives you guys send a broken link
from time to time times we get them all
the time but there's no way for you to
test that if I know I did this myself
you know just as Lanie for the Lincoln
she sent me a broken link anyway his
lady and I still do talk all the time
okay there is a possibility of his
[ __ ] being real that's what we're
saying here but in this scenario Jim
natural [ __ ] it's a total lie okay you
know what it's time for that there it is
she did the she did the French thing so
I was listening to it and it reminded me
of other conversations we've had about
fans because it's just so funny cuz like
you go and you're doing this thing and
you're like I want to create this
podcast for my fans and I want to let
them into my life and you you always
every time you have the conversation
you're always like I want to let the
fans into my life but here's the line of
course every time you're like this is
this is this is where it ends she goes
like I want to talk about sex on the
podcast and and and sexuality abroad
fine everything's a good time but then
Lisa has to go but that doesn't mean I
want to have sex with you right well you
have to clarify now it's kind of like
this cup is sold with hot coffee on it
and it says don't burn yourself you know
what I'm saying something
that so if I'm disclosing like I'm going
to have open conversations with porn
stars and other people and it's gonna be
you know very sexually enlightening but
has nothing to do with us don't make it
about us I still don't want to have sex
with this fan so are the fans they're
not involved in the podcast she's just
saying in general you know what I've
said no but this week's episode that
drops on the Lisa and experience is a
Q&A and I was smart I'm getting smarter
I didn't filter the questions because
then I would have hated everybody for a
month or two so I actually had my
producer read the emails he filtered the
questions and sent the good one so he
got to read the 500 sex proposals weird
let me see your feets you know what by
the way feet nice but you know why do
you want to lousy ones read though I
mean the lousy ones being rather fun
sometimes when people are saying
competitive I do
humanity so the exposure is just I'd
rather live in my own oblivia man I love
varlets someone else seek therapy for
what they've had to read than me or most
guys that you date or most guys that
you'll like you'll fall in love with her
sleep with do they try to like compete
with what you've been through or they
polar opposites of like you know it's
it's it's a two totally different worlds
and lives you know creating something in
a brightly lit room having an experience
in front of other people in the room and
knowing that people are gonna watch the
mental aspect of that is completely
different than an intimate relationship
or an intimate setting which is two
people without lights blazing on you
without a dude telling you like move
your hair you know what I mean so it's
it's very very different and I can tell
a guy's potential by meeting with him by
seeing if he's nervous around me or the
things that he says it's pretty easy to
read at this point where I'm just like
yeah this could work or this desert so
you're not looking for the same thing
you had in film so like basically there
was a guy who was not in great shape
with failed erections that's a good
thing maybe special perhaps he does yeah
guys do fail erections on set as well by
the way i'm so triggered right now by
this this lil angelo ball story is like
the highlight because if you remember
you and I talked about tried to steal
the flag in China when I was on your
show before and I was so
happy he went to jail remember yeah I
was like this is amazing American goes
and doesn't realize the value in the
trip that he has doesn't doesn't value
the college education he's getting goes
and tries to steal a flag and gets put
in jail when that kid got returned to
his parents he was not good sorry yeah
he died yeah he died after he came back
he died yeah they sent him back when
they sent aback you as almost well you
know it's so like did these kids not
catch that story they're saying that uh
yeah three UCLA basketball guys and
trying to have basketball guys that's
how much I know about sports but you're
right the basketball guy that you're
favored yeah they're just say it right
there are young Hooper's yeah three
young Hooper's who play for the UCLA
college they were shoplifting Gucci in
China yeah she's a thing of the past
with the rappers and now the kids want
the Louis Vuitton talking Slick Rick
days it was stealing polo Cologne they
were stealing adidas back then with polo
and a car yeah they stole a bunch of
coogee sweaters is what I see here
they're in China and they may get like
serious jail time
first they won't but I know you're
saying they could yeah we now have a
relationship with China North Korea that
kid was [ __ ] thank you
that kid was [ __ ] and doing something
stupid like that I mean it's just that
are you doing teachers you teach it
shows us that they just don't understand
the impact the history the different
culture but these kids it's like you go
on a trip you get a shoplift you get
have to you have to fill out tax
paperwork to bank items back like Louis
Vuitton do they not know that part of it
right like would you buy a hand over
$5,000 you need to have the receipt for
that because you're taking it back over
the border well one of the writ could've
just been a gift one of the things is
with like this Auto kid is it's not even
the history it's that people here
there's very little consequences now
like right everyone's kind of nice to
each other and you don't say mean [ __ ]
and most of us can't comprehend a place
where you just you steal a little flag
and you're put in jail for 15 years just
doesn't make sense you know I wouldn't
be opposed to us going back to that here
too much stealing the flag and you go to
jail for now why are you like a hardcore
conservative a crime no no but I just
think they were just getting a little
bit I think things are a little bit
reckless at times and I think you know
we're seeing a temperature
late in everywhere from sports to
mainstream media to you know all of
these things that are happening or just
turbulent condoms and porn should be
they should be mandated or no they're
mandating it and I think it's how
they're trying to get it out of LA well
know that we already did not pass so
that's no or a topic on the docket that
did not pass and it was just a very
confusing thing because every article
written about it was misleading and
nobody really ended up knowing where it
ended but when it came to election time
it would have cost in the state about
five million dollars just to put it into
action and the state really needs that
money for other things that are more
important you know that's really why
would it cost five million dollars just
a kind of a task force in place that
comes and trains the industry and
inspects the sets and gets OSHA involved
and let everyone know because you have
to educate people you can't just enforce
laws it's kind of like you own a salon
and the State Board of Cosmetology comes
to you with this guidebook they inspect
your place they give you one try then
after that they show up whenever they
want it would have been something like
this that takes a lot of people how many
people would have volunteered for that
and say people work for you SATA have to
go incest UFC fighter you know much
better be the [ __ ] show bit of porn
five million it would've been all the
volunteers you know there's a five
hundred people that want to do this gig
what a great game they're just sorting
through the volunteers the wrong
intention though said I've watched them
it's [ __ ] it's it's like it's a movie
who would she watch let's talk about
this I watched jenna jameson shoot a
lesbian scene I watched The Belladonna
do something in her house yeah that was
on her husband shot her in her house
doing like a giant dildo scene with
another girl and then I watched one
average price one and then what was at
RJ when was a Walmart and what was the
guy's trunk open and he was selling [ __ ]
out the back that was the handheld thing
guy with the cameras holding the light
right and pointing I saw all three take
away yeah
the highest budget one was uh I didn't
it was like watching a regular movie it
was sanitized right yeah and then
watching the the two guys [ __ ] a girl
I'm a budget no that was the medium one
Oh
a guy named Mark stone was the director
just screaming to people it was really
fun to watch anymore give me more
Chicago accent that's the stuff that I
think that I miss I missed the
quirkiness of some of the weirdos that I
regularly had to engage with and
interact because when you look back on
it you know you get older you start to
really accept people for who they are
right you start to really embrace the
uniqueness in some people and so mark
stone yelling unset' meanwhile the guys
trying to stay hard he's scaring
everyone I mean I was on the back of a
horse for a hustler movie we did it was
Obama's Nayland Palin and it was a movie
that we shot on Halloween to make sure
that we could release it for election
day so you know what a short turnaround
that is and one of the scenes they just
decided like tomatoes and we're gonna
shoot it on Halloween I remember it was
just a circus but they took us up to
this ranch and they put me on the guy
that's playing Obama on the back of his
horse and of course the horse trainer
comes out and he's like you know don't
spook the horse don't do this well the
director was one of those directors and
so of course we're on a cliff by a
canyon the director yells at us of
something he wants to do spooks the
horse the horse takes off I'm only
sitting back saddled because we really
didn't expect the word I'm off the horse
and I mean I remember thinking like man
I don't know how we're gonna get this
scene done like I was sure this guy's
pretty freaked out yeah and the last
thing he's gonna want to do right now is
you know get wood was it what it wasn't
an easy day then to include the horse in
the scene they made us do the scene on a
Bay of hail and they had a big bay and
they drive at us and they had us on this
and they had the horse in the scene so
of course the horse kept eating the hay
sure so the guy was so freaked out by
the horse mind you know as we're doing
it we'd be doing this Unitas rubber you
see this
snotty big nosed horse come in take
another bite stop and look - I know it's
just like this cannot be over fast
enough yeah that's kind of creepy I'm an
animal in Florentine it's creepy the
whole thing was just a bad idea mark
stone died by the way did you know mark
or no
I did oye passed away I didn't know that
I haven't see him he was a his BA he
helped create the AVN award show he was
really good tonight host and he was
really nice man
I see okay okay liver cancer Wow only 61
[ __ ] when you hosted were you impressed
by the reading ability of the stars when
they would be standing in front of the
teleprompter to announce the upcoming
movies that were being nominated you
know I don't remember that to be honest
with I just remember it being like
worrying about my own my own [ __ ] as I
came back up each time I don't remember
anything anybody else but there's some
reading problems in the industry my
friends used to like so what I really
enjoyed going avian I always took my
civilian friends with me and always
rolled with like four or five people and
then they'd sit down at the table and
they'd pick out the little sit the the
flyer and they'd circle the titles the
movies they wanted to win just by the
titles you know and then the girls would
go up to read and I would explain to
them this is why dialogue takes so long
you know the teleprompters right there
the girls had a couple cocktails or the
guy the guys are no better and so
they're really struggling with it and I
can remember one girl who I will not
mention she said why is this in Spanish
we were like I knew she couldn't really
read I'm just like intoxicated you know
listen it does take a little practice to
read a teleprompter you have to know
what pace it works for you you know I've
always had an app for my iPad so I could
learn how to really read it and you have
to put a little time in but really it
really is two-sided because on one end
people are going like well these girls
you know the industry chews them up and
spits them out and then they've got no
place to go after but at the same time
they didn't bother to learn to read yeah
any point like they didn't pick up any
skills some maybe troubles when they get
in somebody's already troubled yeah yeah
but you know what do you start making
money you have the option to do whatever
you want absolutely right money is power
so you start making money you create
your schedule I mean these girls get to
make their own schedule they do have to
get to decide who they work with and who
they don't it really is ultimately their
choice whether they stand up and make
that choice or not
did you know one to blimp did you want
to raise a child I did who's on your do
you keep on your no list oh yeah how
many pretty probably like 70% of the
business Wow
to work for a narrow group of people who
were not crazy would make someone go on
your no list a guy or a talent no talent
who is late just didn't take care of
themselves like remember our girls
showing up late like three hours late
for a shoot for a girl girl shoot and
she's like oh we read this rave last
night and I looked out at her arm and
she still has the paper bracelet which I
know you're thinking the same thing as
me Sam
this means this girl did not take a
shower small terrific there was a shower
on set that had no hot water but it was
a shower and I was like the only way
this is taking place is if we rearrange
this scene a bit which is basically
explained somebody put her in this cold
shower Pulp Fiction dirt basically yeah
so you know you don't want to do a scene
with a girl who is [ __ ] dancing on
ecstasy at a rave for five hours I did
not and then slept and then just woke up
and great three I so it's got me in the
middle of the afternoon yeah those are
really the little things and also when
you start to work with people you really
enjoy there's no need to open up and
work with more people because you're
creating a sexual product and the more
connection you have with those people
the more trust the more you enjoy each
other each time you see each other you
just know that you're gonna be
guaranteed to get a good scene yeah yeah
okay yeah I like working with coworkers
you like sure how are you liking this oh
I like it
I do too I like it I like working with
Jim I just somebody photoshopped a photo
of Ric Flair with a giant piece Oh
Travis for the gates - Lisa you're
actually you're you're you like athletes
that's your year you're yeah they're
okay yeah have you ever had sex with Ric
Flair no I have not but why do I have a
beard right there can I see that again
wow that's what I'd look like that's not
say I'm a fan [ __ ] he likes to know why
you chose that color okay yeah I want to
wear it as a hat
I don't mind it it's neat and tidy it
looks pretty good it's conditional it
does actually accent the cleavage in the
photo but I would have liked it to match
my hair color just a suggestion what's
what's it been like for you to be back
at these conventions because obviously
you're flying on the wall but at the
same time like you're dealing with
a lot of people right a lot of fans
coming summer sure great I can say that
you know probably when I was at my
busiest time I was more burned-out and I
didn't really get it and now that I come
back and I'm having these random
conversations I find them actually
pretty entertaining like you know for
the most part here's a lot of couples
that come to these events so it's really
nice to talk to them it's really neat to
see they go out once a year and buy a
bunch of toys and have a wild night
exotica what have you and as for the
guys like I get to have these like
conversations with them like you know if
you could really break it down like how
many hours a week do you think you're
watching porn like you know is this
something we should talk juice he it is
a problem and I become truly entertained
by and there was this guy that was so
traumatized that he forgot one of his
magazines to get signed by me and my
security and I are just like he's like
having a minor meltdown I said to him I
don't really know how you're gonna go on
without this extra signature on this
magazine from 1994 and we were we were
literally dying inside I gave the guy a
bunch of extra stock we didn't got to
bring the magazine yeah and he was so
devastated OCD you know what you should
do on your part you should find the guys
that like spend hours and hours and
hours watching porn and like interview
those guys on your podcast and like we
can break them down yeah you should have
like a counseling kind of snowboarder
chat yeah just like just like get to get
in their heads a little bit you know get
them to be dirty like to say dirty
things how awkward that would be talk
dirty the lisa-ann like try to be like
you washed her you're a fan now say what
you want to say how awful they'd be out
of healing rate it'd be like a guy who's
not funny just repeating jokes he's seen
I would listen that all day I just want
to [ __ ] you actually in real life find
that appealing yeah women would listen
to it for sure I do actually tell them
that they should work as hard at finding
real vagina as they do it watching porn
right so my hope by the next time I see
you you've gotten some real vagina like
you know do you like just try to get out
of your house and away from your screen
and get some yeah it really is funny
because people will spend hours and
hours and hours and hours searching for
the
a video that they want to watch but they
want to shoot me how many unique
visitors a day do you think pornhub gets
I'm 1,500 oh my god I'm gonna go I'm
gonna take the over 80 million what 80
million unique visitors a day Wow
oh my god yeah I know really that's a
lot right a lot of people it's a lot of
people worldwide but that's a lot of
people should get more well what could
you do let's talk about it let's market
you a little bit I'm just hoping that my
stupid character podcast can somehow get
involved with pornhub couldn't you
couldn't couldn't because pornhub
sponsors a lot of things that even porn
they're trying to branch out for sure
right I bet I bet you could be what chip
could be the first comedian of pornhub
or you could be the first good review
has seen a week you know like you know
chip chip person ChIP chip person
reviews for pornhub whoo that'll be fun
I think it'd be great and I mean you
don't use stars of course you have to
have another figure of so she's like
yelling at red chip is a character of
the gym that's a great gym is a
character the chip does it yeah points
so another thing I write now I started
doing which is interesting is strip
clubs that feral eyes they still want me
to come to their clubs even if I don't
take my clothes off paved a host like
this Friday night I'll be at XS and
Staten Island and they just have me
chill I come in take pictures with
everybody
it's like a super social event for me I
get to play dress-up because remember
what are you doing radio you stop
putting on heels and dressing you sure
you don't even need make-up I mean so
it's like okay now once or twice a month
I get out the door and to carry on
flight only because I'm just going in
and out for the night usually and it's
so much fun and it's just social enough
so did you have to like do you have to
be away for a certain amount of time for
three years or whatever before because I
remember like when you first got out of
it I probably talked to you like a year
after and you were like kind of
distancing yourself from all of it just
I just it was such a bad breakup
remember the score involved there was
people trained there was death threats
there was just the business treated me
like a gang and like I tried to when I
left that gang the gang retaliated
against me it was never really fans
although there have been some creepy
people that have not made my
pleasant but it was really the
inside-out and it's an interesting thing
because now when I go back it's the
first this is the first year out of the
three years where I've done events and
I'm starting to see some of these people
in person again and it's interesting
because they have to realize that you
have to have a plan and you can't hate
on the person that had the plan right
but the business wants to be done with
you before you're done with it right and
there's a lot of people that did very
nasty things to me that now I'm actually
getting to have face-to-face
conversations with and it's a beautiful
thing to face someone that did something
horrific to you and just sit them down
in a very calm and respectful way and
address it what wouldn't I hate forty
what do you say what do you consider
horrible that's someone good giving away
my personal information my family's
personal information addresses phone
number which is a performer or someone
else this was performers and why did
they do it just to be spiteful and how
they responded to you talking to them I
think there's a chance that they
realized that if it did ever happen to
them and the shoe was on the other foot
that it would be a miserable place to be
and it's an unfair thing to do to
somebody else which you wouldn't want
done to yourself but when you like sit
them down like how do they how do they
deal with seeing you face they're very
squirming right they're very squirming
tonight or no I meant to it was just a
pretty no they're pretty quiet they're
pretty taken back by the whole fact that
I'm willing to sit down now face to face
and I will corner somebody and I will
wait until I see that there's no one
really around to remove them from the
situation it's a good ten-minute
face-to-face talk but don't forget about
the people you hurt so what do you say
to them when you first walk up to them
you want to have this check how do you
Brad you say like let's have a I just
say hey do you have a minute I think
it's a good idea for us to have a
conversation and has any of them said no
no but one of them looked like she was
gonna cry the second it started well
yeah because I can't imagine like one of
them was a guy this weekend I got to sit
down with that exotica and this is a guy
that regularly believes a lot of women
in the business and has done a lot of
bad things to a lot of people and he
walks a really fine line and I'm
surprised at the risks he takes it I
told him I said you know I think you're
reckless with the fact that many people
know your secrets and you shouldn't be
so evil when you have more to hide than
others so I just want you to think this
through
why when you say secrets do you mean
sexual secrets or money what kind of
secrets or behavior secrets behavior
like the agents that illegally cash the
girls checks at check cashing stores
that get fake IDs in Arizona for foreign
girls that are booking privates
illegally you know oh you know all the
stuff that goes down to business because
you've got girls in here for years it's
just these people don't realize like you
know don't don't mess with people when
you have that much going on when you
have that much dirt you shouldn't be
trying to put other people's dirt so do
they know that you know they've put
their they put your [ __ ] out there or
they shocked that you know that they put
your [ __ ] out there they know because
some of them are stupid enough down the
road after a period of time to brag
about things and to just continue to
talk about it so it got back to me in a
situation where I know how everything
started I knew who the ringleaders were
I knew who they got after them I know
who they're still getting to carry their
torch they still have some of the young
girls that don't even know me carrying
the torch and talking about me
negatively in situations you left the
business who cares well people get
jealous yeah when you do it like when
you leave on top and on your own terms
anything when you leave in a good way
they're always anything he's right and
you think that are stuck in this they
feel stuck in the business they don't
really have any other marketable skills
so why are they happy you're gone then
it's better more room for them to move
up well this is what you would think but
when you're when you're running in a
scared mindset when you live in a
desperation in a space where you haven't
thought for yourself anybody else who
has more than you is the enemy okay
that's really what I've learned in the
psychology of it like I've taken
incredible amount of time to read and to
really understand the mindset and how
people can get in this frame of mind and
and it's really I had to stop and say
this has nothing to do with me this is
all about them one of the things you
were talking about on your on your
podcast I was listening to was there's
this I can't remem skp me but there's
this woman on Twitter who's become kind
of famous for exposing oh yeah Mia
Khalifa that's what yeah she [ __ ] over
athletes right she's this ex but she's
also next porn star has now gotten into
sports correct and but she whereas Lisa
like when you started I feel like it was
almost like this thing of embracing like
yeah I love athletes and i hook up with
athletes and I have lot
of athletes their friends and lot lots
of athletes that are partnering button
but it was this like let's all celebrate
this enjoyable and you know I get the
Act III get the access to these hot
young men why shouldn't I enjoy it but I
never exposed never exposed to anybody
and she has like developed this
following now if people because she's
exposing DMS all the time why does she
do that I mean to me it's kind of shitty
like if something unless someone's being
a dick but if someone's just reaching
out like and you're not interested why
don't you say you're not interested like
she is of this new generation where they
want fame from dragging other people and
they can't find away it's you're right
it's quicker it's quicker yeah you know
shows like TMZ and the way the news has
slanted a bit we've started to have more
fun with other people's mishaps than by
finding a positive way to brand
ourselves ourselves and now she's
actually just reaching out to people and
one guy is like no I know what you did
like a funny response tonight right so
it'll it'll go up you know go down just
as fast but it's just you know and also
like one of the guys that really upset
me was it a Wilmer Contreras I think the
baseball player well it was over the
summer he just slid into her DMS and
like I was a bum a big fan of sin she
blasted him and she always waits to like
they're playing a game so then it could
be up on the doors her timing is
ridiculous and I thought to myself like
she's following him so he can DM her he
get musters up the courage you have no
idea how many months it might take
somebody to muster up the courage to
finally send you a DM and admit that
they're a fan like we have a
responsibility to look at that like
either ignore it don't accept DMS from
people but to just shame somebody what
Wilson Contreras what did she say about
him did he say anything shitty and you
know didn't the DMS were just like
honestly the DM z-- looked exactly the
same as the DM z-- that [ __ ] loaf was
accused of sending on Facebook it was
just like I want to [ __ ] no no not that
okay it was the just who said that well
I would reduce you to show off in a
minute yeah but this guy this guy for
the Cubs he's sending their DMS they're
just like hey I'm a fan hey you know I
just wanted to reach out but it was just
oh like and then even
when the Cubs are playing the Dodgers in
the playoffs she was out in LA shaming
him and like videoing him and putting it
on her social media and while he's
playing a game I'm thinking like this
kid is doing something with his life
he's in the playoffs he's a major league
baseball that's like a 10-month sport do
you not understand how hard he's working
she wrote here's me wrote here I'm sure
you get this a lot but I'm a big fan of
you and they put a bunch of dumb little
smiling emojis and then he writes that
just grinds Jam like the [ __ ] emoji
and then he writes it will be great if
you just say hi and she responds by B ye
what a [ __ ] she's awful oh yeah and
then and then he was fun and again hello
well good morning
then he writes good afternoon then he
writes my friend then you know a while
later he writes I hope you're doing good
he's just you know what great I'll watch
for us now now he's being annoying now
he's being annoying
you know why with Twitter you have the
option to not accept direct messages
from people that you don't want direct
messaging you you know there's tons oh I
guess I agree I tell guys this if you
send three messages and let's say
they're over a span of a week and you
get no response don't send the form
that's he sent way too many messages
without a response that we agree on that
but still he's forward on the road
athletes are bored of the road it's very
lonely whatever whatever whatever she
still shouldn't respond yeah maybe not
but I I'm less annoyed at her for this
when I see that this guy said 1 2 3 4 5
some [ __ ] stop it send one so you two
here's a good one for you there's a very
well-known girl I won't mention her name
who was at a party with a bunch of
athletes that I know Scarlett Johansson
okay and she was just talking they
called me from the party to tell me that
she was there talking [ __ ] so I called
her agent and I said she dies or you
have her picked up those are your two
choices and he had her picked up in five
minutes so I got to see her for the
first time this week at exotica for the
first time since the incident I didn't
say a word but I walked in front of her
booth and I just stared at her with my
security behind me I just stared at her
like next time you do die the cheat did
she know that you knew
she knew because her agent said don't go
to parties in Los Angeles and be around
people and be just mad [ __ ] talking
lisa-ann it's completely [ __ ]
unnecessary and it might get you killed
at this point I am retaliating right
right so enough is enough all of my
people at parties are like and also you
go to every club person you know make
sure she cannot get into anywhere I want
her privileges revoked I'm gonna follow
me a Khalifa send her a DM this could be
great for you yes and ur thirsty you
know a really good dick pic yeah well
send it let's steal what no I have a
couple of pretty good penis pictures
wait do you mean a your phone or on the
hard drive of your computer so cute on
my phone there's a reason why Jim and
the iCloud do not get along don't fear
the cloud as you can only imagine Yeah
right I don't fear the cloud well you
don't have that much time
what are you see we're gonna see the
scene so I'm one of those people that's
like the cloud right oh wow disappoint
you because it would show you the
healthy meals that I'm making them
photographing and sending my flat
friends yeah yeah my plants like you'd
be like what Slee sans cloud I'm gonna
follow up and they see she I let's see
if I can I don't think you're verified I
love to see you slide in there I'll be
so great yeah we'll see slide in there
the deal I'll say some smooth [ __ ] loaf
in there tell him to come to the
microphone you know what I'm in there
yeah I am going to assume that [ __ ] loaf
is not the real name of said pigeons
actually it's his birth name yeah yeah
its middle name is the loaf yeah because
during the birth a lot of times during a
birth almond woman will [ __ ] and that
was what happened when he was born I
have no kids right and this whole
childbirth thing is horrific oh [ __ ] we
were talking in the hallway and you
seemed somewhat normal microphone there
you go I'm normal okay somewhat alright
to talk about why you're in here
so let's okay so so [ __ ] look we found
out uh nope foods just being delivered
up in the studio the way we roll yeah
[ __ ] love was he was sending direct
messages on Facebook
oh my a while ago sure okay let's talk
about a while how old are you 27 and
how old how long is a while to you six
months a year a year okay okay is that a
while let's just go just go okay so he's
sending him to a couple of co-workers
and then also all their friends did you
mean to or were you hitting a feature
where you didn't know it was mass going
out did you think it was an one on one
thing it was individual it was
individual and were you drinking and did
you feel it was appropriate working in
corporate sorry I'm liking so you know
[ __ ] low in today's world that could be
considered sexual right that's why I'm
just saying I'm making sure that you
know it's not sexual harrass but did you
apologize a horse did you get brought
out like did people tell on you they
came in and what was the direct message
that we were also concerned about what
was the text of the message that you
wrote I believe it was four words uh-huh
I just want to [ __ ] but it wasn't in
that I thought was under the influence
of something I'm just so impressed he
still has a job she had written you you
wrote her a bunch of you got going
different that was a different person in
person he didn't write this to that but
no no but there was one that you wrote a
bunch too and she was writing you back
every time I was saying like she wasn't
wearing be back at all how many times
you writing you back at all and you
still went and you wrote me back twice
but then and then there was another four
so I'm saying a Happy New Year I hope
your days go
listen Contreras hope your day is going
well here like Jason running after you
psycho wait Happy New Year isn't good
for someone you're not interested in
well it's just the tone that he's going
with you're like okay this guy has
nothing else going on but to message me
a message right now like I so what was
that was the context of the I just want
a [ __ ] message I don't remember I just I
really don't remember what that's
actually worse yeah a lot worse rule
number one don't [ __ ] where you eat no
don't date at work don't date in your
apartment building don't date within a
three-mile radius like don't send
messages to those people if you have to
put a radius on all of your apps and say
I cannot direct
message people that are co-workers like
trusted with the Facebook app bless this
kid's heart
I mean I'm 20-something 7gr you how many
are you already dating apps like tinder
or Grindr no dating apps cuz that's a
great part for place for you to express
yourself maybe I'll start because I
really should start why are you not on a
dating app surprise I never really yeah
I was yeah I was on a bunch of them
how'd it go not great you know like you
I've met a decent amount of people but
it's almost like with all these choices
you're like you go out you know I have a
lot of don't know bad ones just dinner
there's a lot of dinners and for guys
they have to pay so it doesn't work it's
something to do I always whatever you
want even check how many times what the
girls actually look like the photo that
they were using a decent amount a couple
of times they were fatter always
beautiful but that disappointment yep
yeah well not only that women really
know what their angle is they really
know how to shoot their pictures now
they really know how to filter retouch
what have you yeah and so it is an
illusion it's really an illusion when
you see them straight on they look
different if you're holding you if your
profile photo it looks like it was taken
with the Hubble I know you're a [ __ ]
monster I'm so nervous that I'm gonna
show up and it's gonna be not the person
that I expected and then it's like ah
well yeah because you're such a catch
and I think you'd be happy if someone
showed up for messages with no response
and he's like blogging out let's take
the dates nobody's not doing that it's
the [ __ ] date that's okay by the way
the four messages is the less creepy one
do you imagine I just want to [ __ ] how
did this come into the workplace did you
get written up in Quincy it was it was I
wasn't working here oh but I was working
in another department I see and I didn't
think it was all gonna come out on the
air ever some of the some of the girls
thought it would be fun to let Jim and
myself know oh cool
in screen grabbing him and sending you
updates all the time without like oh
yeah too fun and and you've probably
encountered this before the girls come
in and they go yet no Anthony's creepy
and Anthony gets all indignant about it
he's like I'm not [ __ ] creepy I don't
know why they keep saying that I'm not
creepy and they're like I'm crazy okay
here's the deal yeah you're [ __ ]
here's the evidence
yeah you're creepy sucks not being
perverted though I'm not but it's just
cuz you didn't you know force trade is
like that's a bit - she read him I've
probably done that though well I think
you know a lot of probably done stuff
it's well I'm glad you're doing better
but I do next time I see you I'd love to
see you on some dating apps and I'd like
to read the reviews that can get on the
dating so yeah how come you have to
leave at 9:15 9:20 I'm gonna walk over
to morning men visit the guys in the
studio
what's morning men it's a sports channel
yeah oh I don't know those guys sport Oh
mad dog yeah in the mad dog gym is it
chris broussard oh he's afternoon he
doesn't it's Mike Babcock in Evan Cohen
okay yeah fun guys you know we're in a
fantasy football league together I'm six
and three in that Lake which I just took
a L and like I'm so upset I wanted to
come in here seven and two and be like
I'm on a seven-game win streak and
gnomes are you playing with my no not
this year
no he loves playing we checked out of
that League but 19 other leagues doing
pretty well I did fantasy baseball last
year I don't know if I could do it again
this year is it boring it's so
time-consuming to stay in the top three
you know in your league because I
finished in last my first year playing
so then this year I became obsessed it's
just against all the hoes I mean it took
20 30 hours a week to manage that team
oh my god but I just wanted to finish
and be competitive and stay in the top
three all season which I did and then I
ended up finishing in fourth place like
tied for third how often do you do radio
Sunday nights I do a show from 10:00
p.m. to 1:00 a.m. called overtime Monday
nights is Lisa and does fantasy 10:00
p.m. to 12 a.m. midnight and they're
both on Sirius XM fantasy sports are
[ __ ] love does something not really like
fantasy sports but he gay he's got a
guy's attention
Oh generate all the way around a sore
throat I do this for the challenge of it
you know a lot of the only money leagues
I'm in are charity charity and then all
the money goes to charity generate
relatives that every sporting event was
ruined by gambling every Super Bowl
there are people fighting my dad and my
uncle being yard fighting I'm like I'm
never doing that over sports by the way
you are not the charity your bookie is
the chair how about strip clubs do you
frequent no that's an X that's an X
let's take this kid into a strip club
strip club addicted he'd be living out
of a car after a couple months cuz you
know DP the first would be like so I met
this girl and she really likes me she
really likes me
you know I'm going over to her place
she's me to help her move go to Atlantic
City together because if some of those
girls like strip clubs whicker's the way
they touch you like I remember one girl
was so good she gave me lap dances it
was hot and then she's given this other
guy lap dances and then she's looking
over at me like I'm boy work like I knew
what she was doing but she was great
that's people watching in the world as
at strip clubs there's no doubt it's
just such a cast of characters I saw
some of the craziest [ __ ] happen in
clubs it was always the girls like girls
getting in fights were they just like
one by one break off their acrylic nails
I think and when I see that co-ed down
I'd be like all right let me get locked
in my dressing room and just peek out
once in a while and see what's going on
weekly yeah I don't know if she got
fired she did one of our live shows then
she got in a fight with play games her
is it's so one extreme or the other
right and I think as a woman maybe when
she gets older she'll find her way she
definitely needs to talk with someone
and find a way to channel her energy
it's all about like now when I travel so
I don't kill people I listened to the
headspace
app what's heads face meditation so I'm
in the airport and instead of wanting to
slug the guy that I know is just taking
photos of everything that I do in the
airport I'm just like it's okay not all
the time when you think you do not take
that many pictures what do they say I'll
never jerk off to you again tweet about
it you know and those she was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know now with the interaction
that they can throw back at you on
social media it's just not worth even
addressing it we've lost kind of our
rights in that situation you just gotta
do your best to ignore any interaction
because it can backfire if you start
yelling at somebody you know someone
else's get a video that what do you just
ask them I just approach to an assonance
it looks of course no one wants to be
videoed when they're eating I just don't
eat out anymore unless I'm traveling but
because you do ask me I did just you go
you could be chewing and they'll walk up
to you like hey kid I'm a photo you're
like man I'm [ __ ] eating but you got
it you got it really watch now because
they will video the negative interaction
then next thing you know teams he's got
young there's great it's like if I go in
I'm taking the guy down oh yeah yeah if
you go like yeah can I take a photo with
you actually I'm eating right now oh
okay but then I'm gonna video yeah just
really creeped out on you absolutely